oui ce soir encore la confusion est
totale le mieux que nous puissions faire
c'est de vous montrer ce qu a été la
première journée au mans de steve
mcqueen
la députée d'assez bonne heure ce matin
à l'hôtel des environs du mans où le
second des 12 heures de sebring est
descendu c'est là que nous l'avons
rencontré en compagnie non seulement des
responsables du film tient mais aussi du
directeur sportif de chez porsche croire
avoir théâtre qu'en est il exactement au
sujet de vos assureurs en fait qui forme
l'opposition à ma participation aux 24
heures vient surtout de la compagnie qui
produit le film
je ne suis pas un coureur automobile
je suis un coureur moto syrie libre mais
la course automobile m'intéresse bushido
règlement de sa prison je suis très
reconnaissant à porsche je suis monté à
sebring
je dois faire ma vie et je dois essayer
une fois de plus je ferai ce fait sinon
moi et là le spin off you like speed
d'entrée mais la vitesse speed dial in
your eyes ça donne froid a répondu steve
il goûte le danger de la course
automobile
non ce qui est encore plus dangereuse
que célèbre moto
bon timing est mort à la suite d'un but
à l'autre et vous donne mille décès de
24 heures office you
oui je dois m il y aura une voiture est
une porsche 908 munis de caméras il
faudra l'essayer et il se veut alors que
je la conduis moi même oui steve est
très désireux de courir les 24 heures du
mans
plus qu'aux films sur le mans qui sera
réalisé par john sturges il rêve de
participer à la célèbre course depuis
qu'il est enfant
devra-t-il se contentait alors de faire
des allers et venues dans la porsche 911
miss à 2 face à disposition par la firme
allemande
non toute façon c'est la voiture avec
laquelle vivent a couru assez brille
toujours encore une union de départ
c'est brillant on l'a modifiée pour
prendre deux caméras de films
on a fait une révision générale et donc
on va voir demain si tu vois bien avec
ses caméras s'il va toujours bien en
ligne droite et tous les problèmes qui
vient avec
vous avez vu tout à l'heure sous la
ligne droite des hunaudières à côté de
vestiges est-ce que c'était du repérage
en vue de la course
oui je lui ai donné quelques conseils
pour le cas où il peut piloter dommage
de donner quelques conseils de mon
expérience
danse était certaine virage du circuit
et on a eu donc un petit on a échangé
les opinions et tout ça c'est plutôt
optimiste mais vous savez moi dans la
vie si toujours optimiste on verra
comment ça va aller je vois le problème
des légendes l'assurance je vois le
problème de steve steve dans son coeur
est un pilote et j'ai été pilote je sais
ça veut dire je sais ce travail à dire
d'être au mans et du risque de ne pas
pouvoir courir c'est très dur